well the future of transportation is
here check this out autonomous vehicles
have arrived in las vegas and you can
now request a robo taxi right here on
the las vegas strip thank you so much
for staying with us here at 4 30. i'm
christian costas and i'm kirsten joyce
the company motional is partner with
lyft to launch the ioniq 5 it's a robo
taxi that debuted today that's right we
caught up with the company behind the
technology offering customers a
driverless option
[Music]
right here
a futuristic dream now a reality in las
vegas self-driving vehicles moving
customers up and down the las vegas
strip oh well we'll have to try it out
love technology love it promote it but
we don't need to replace every human we
spotted the ioniq five vehicles
operating along the strip on tuesday zep
dawson is the company's director of
commercial fleet operations he tells us
the project promises to provide more
reliable affordable and sustainable
transportation in the valley there's a
lot of work going into this to make sure
that safe transportation and we even
have with when it goes driverless it
doesn't mean there won't be any humans
at all in the loop there still will be
humans such as rva which is a remote
vehicle assistance motional is mapping
out the valley while testing its
vehicles to help with the complexity
intersections and traffic with cameras
both inside and outside the vehicle we
look at this as an opportunity to really
show that robo taxis are the best way
for people to get around we have a lot
of nighttime driving bright lights on
the strip
there's a lot of wide lanes there's big
intersections when you request this
driverless vehicle via lyft passengers
will each have screens inside sensors
will help navigate the vehicle up and
down the las vegas boulevard while also
providing immediate human assistance if
needed once you get inside that vehicle
you realize okay
i still have access to help if i need it
and if there's something going on i know
i can reach a human still
a bright future says this california
tourist as the digital wave continues to
sweep las vegas we'll try it out
eventually i think give it some time
well you might have noticed the vehicles
in our story had passengers in the front
seat well a spokesperson for emotional
tells us today's soft launch will have
human drivers until the end of the year
that's when the vehicles will operate on
their own